hey youtubers Happy New Year so a whole
bunch of Rick and Morty coming really
soon so I wanted to do my top 10 most
powerful characters so here we go
there is a new round of the Rick and
Morty giveaway going on right now it's
for a copy of the new hardback comic
book all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything so I
try to give preference to the more main
characters but I did include side
characters in episodes but I give them
priority over the really minor
characters they don't really talk about
that much like crumb populist Michael so
honorable mention starts with crumb bob
ulis Michael ice-t in the chrome Ilan's
so you know relatively powerful
characters in their own right chrome
populist Michael an amazing assassin I
just love killing people but he's
dispatched relatively quickly by Morty
who is asleep at the wheel ice-t is
another really powerful character who's
able to soak a blast from the crummy
Ilan's who they themselves are supposed
to be these omnipotent beings but
because Rick is able to dispatch them
with get schwifty I had to like bump
them down to the bottom of the list to
honorable mention so a lot of the way
that Rick's and Morty's defeat some of
these characters or one-up them bump
them closer to the bottom of the list so
you could argue a little bit about ice-t
like maybe he should have a little
higher place on the list because they do
mythologize him in a pretty extensive
way like they say he's this ageless
wandering alien from the dawn of time
that's actually known as water tea he's
almost like someone that gets kicked out
of the Q continuum his race is called
the number cons they live on alpha beat
reham on the commentary for this get
schwifty episode they even joked that
when they were writing the episode that
they miss their opportunity for a
spin-off game of Thrones with these
characters inside the Rick and Morty
multiverse so if you take it literally
then they are like a very powerful
ancient race of beings but technically
like within the context of the episode
it's treated it as more of a joke so
they're not like quite as powerful as
they like fart and his people so number
10 starts to list with c-137 Rick's
Morty not to be confused with c-137
Morty which might be a different person
there's a big theory that c130
Evon rig is not on his first morty you
know maybe his morty like the original
morty is the evil morty so that's a
completely separate thing but for the
purposes of this video we'll just call
this the main version of morty that we
follow through most of the episodes not
necessarily all the episodes but because
we follow c-137 rick most of the time
then this version of morty you could
call the main version of morty for the
TV show so he's at the bottom of the
list because he cancels Rick out but he
is slowly like they've teased it in
season 3 he'll start to become complicit
stop moralizing Rick quite as much
questioning his decisions and turn into
more of a Rick not that he'll
necessarily become a genius in his own
right or anything like that but just
that he's going to continue to absorb
some of Rick's morality and that will
cause him to make more Rick like
decisions number 9 is unity because she
has the power to basically take over an
entire race of beings she controls a
planet until Rick comes in and it all
goes sideways because they lose it in a
party it's implied that unity is just
going to continue to absorb new races to
assimilate them until the entire
universe is one here's how you know
shit's getting real with unity the next
time we see a council of ricks episode
in the background they always put a lot
of funny versions of Rick and Morty just
look for unity Rick and unity Morty that
way you know they'll have infiltrated
the council and we'll start assimilating
the multiverse as well because right now
it seems like they're only contained to
this one universe number eight is the
devil because he's the devil what what
[ __ ] so the devil is such a powerful
concept that the only way that they're
able to get the one up on him is because
Rick is just so powerful and because
he's really bummed out over the course
of his episode he slowly regains his
confidence thanks to summer then as the
devil does pulls a fast one on her
showing you that he is the true devil
true [ __ ] we don't necessarily know
if he's a multi-dimensional being or not
or if this is just the single version of
the devil so far they've only been a
couple characters that we've only seen a
single version of like mr. poopy
butthole seems like he's the only
version of that character that exists in
reality so number seven is fart the
telepathic being from a race that is
going to erratic
eight all solid life forms so he has
powers of telepathy so he can cause as
much damage as he is in proximity to so
the only reason he's lower on this list
is because he's vulnerable to energy
weapons like the one that Morty kills
him with and he's able to be killed by a
morty meaning that he's not as smart as
he looks very powerful but very
short-sighted so ahead of them I put
number six the council of ricks because
collectively they're not quite as smart
as the single c-137 Rick but they're
powerful enough to outsmart the Galactic
government and create this
interdimensional Citadel where they can
hole up and do whatever they want within
reason like if there's a Rick that's
more powerful like c-137 Rick then they
can't really make him do anything but as
Rick himself is the smartest being in
any dimension then even the dumbest of
Rick's is still smarter than almost
everybody else in every dimension number
five is SH Lee my pants the fourth
dimensional being so for obvious reasons
beings that can travel along our
timeline like we would walk down the
street obviously more powerful than
normal characters that exist is three
dimensional beings in any dimension so
also do you know just because like fart
he's easily dispatched by Rick and Morty
I didn't put in towards the top of the
list but just going based on scientific
principles he would be one of the most
powerful characters in existence next on
the list though number four is EEP zan
flora who was basically like the Khan
for c-137
the way they joked about it like the
creator said that you know he might come
back in a future season but because he's
voiced by Stephen Colbert it's just
really hard to get actors like that to
come back so we might see him in a
background I just keep your eyes peeled
for him
because he is just as smart as c-137
Rick who you know technically should be
the smartest person in any dimension
meaning that by default zeep would also
be the most powerful being in any
dimension but the problem is is that he
loves his people in a way that Rick is
kind of ambiguous about like Rick
protects his family but he's really
quick to call a mulligan when he
Cronenberg's his own c-137 universe so
because EEP is a little more generous to
his people
it makes him slightly more vulnerable
not quite as powerful as c-137 Rick even
though
just as smart so shits get a little real
here number three on the list is evil
Morty a lot of people are wondering
maybe this is the original c-137 Morty
but if he's able to outsmart the council
of ricks as well as co-opt a Rick
himself in hijack his brain then he has
to be super high on the list but they
have joked that the character the idea
of evil Morty will come back in the
future just one of those open plot
threads they just kind of let dangle
until they find a good opportunity to
bring him back so you typically he's
associated with council of ricks centric
episodes so that's probably where we'll
see him pop back up again but number two
is mr. poopy butthole just because he
knows he's inside a television show he
seems like the only version of his
character inside the multiverse and in
this post-credit scene we see him
watching the episode as it's happening
to c-137 Rick like as he's being locked
up will Rick it out what's going to
happen tune back in in a year and a half
and see what happens
so obviously number one is c-137 Rick
the most morally gray but not
necessarily evil smart version of Rick
so on the spectrum of Rick's he's not
necessarily super evil but during that
evil Morty episode the evil Rick that's
being controlled by evil Morty tells him
that look you know you're just like a
couple shades away from super evil so on
numerous occasions c-137 rick has been
able to outsmart pretty much everyone in
existence just proving that he's the
smartest person in any dimension making
him the most powerful he's able to
outsmart the crime you law it's like
these giant floaty heads that have crazy
powerful energy beams he's able to
outsmart a fourth dimensional being so
let me know in the comments who's your
favorite most powerful character on Rick
and Morty they don't necessarily have to
be like the most powerful but I love how
open-ended they are with the way they
treat some of these characters like the
ice-t character himself was probably one
of the most funny concepts even if it
wasn't the funniest episode like I was
in my favorite episode but just the way
they treat the ist character because it
sounds like the person that was writing
the episode like Dan Harmon or whoever
just went on like this cocaine-fueled
backstory rant where he just went on and
on and on about building
the world that iced tea or water tea
came from until he found that he had
written an entire episode within an
episode like you have all this water
tea's stuff going on that you know
nothing about but it sounds like
somebody who spent days and days writing
so some of the funniest moments on the
show is when they devolve into like
nonsense rants like that to just go on
and on and on
like you can see them in the meeting
trying to talk to the other writers
about this water tea world where they
just keep going and keep going in
everyone's eyes glaze over and they just
fall asleep so like I said when we see
you know big crowd shots especially
Council of Rick episodes or episodes
like Total Recall you might see some of
these minor characters pop up in the
background so just keep your eyes peeled
but for those of you asking about season
3 there hasn't really been much since
that last animatic teaser that they
released so I had a link to that at the
end of this but the current rumor is
that it's going to drop sometime in
March I would assume that is we get a
little bit closer they'll start to talk
about it more and more like they'll
start releasing more promotional content
but until they start posting stuff don't
expect anything like the bid hold up at
this point is probably some overseas
animation that they're waiting on like
they can't start airing episodes until
they have a certain number of them in
the can ready to air so they're probably
just waiting until they get those last
couple of episodes finished so they can
start rolling them out but I'll say
congratulations to this week's Rick and
Morty giveaway winner Genesis David you
want a copy of the new hardcover comic
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video I'll
just announce the winner the next time I
post a Rick and Morty video so if
there's any special theory videos or
explainer or Easter egg videos you guys
want me to do just let me know in the
comments but they just confirm some
Marvel stuff that's coming down the pipe
they're going to be making an animated
spider-man movie in addition to
spider-man Home Coming so I'll do a
video for that later
so Happy New Year everybody have an
awesome weekend whole bunch of bonus
videos coming I'm so excited about 2017
Rick and Morty is going to be awesome
but there's so much other awesome stuff
that's coming - well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for that
new footage and you can click here for
my big theory video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you
[Music]